most people
i think dieting is the hardest part
right
i i mean you know when you if you talk
about a diet like doing [ __ ]
atkins or keto that's hard because you
have to stay on some regimented [ __ ] and
you're gonna
you're bound to fall off right it's
about changing the actual lifestyle
and it's crazy that i'm even able to
talk about this because like six months
ago
i could tell you about it but i wasn't
living it you know i was [ __ ] eating
cakes and cookies and [ __ ] pounding
sugar and [ __ ] compounding it with
meats and [ __ ] nasty
just eating like a [ __ ] animal like
what the hell am i doing i'm not [ __ ]
thinking about college i'm not in
[ __ ]
rutgers you know having a bowl of
[ __ ] apples having an apple jacks
a bowl at [ __ ] three in the morning i
haven't had [ __ ] cereal in six months
because i eat two boxes of it
and it's not even sugary cereal it's
some like old man cereal you know
and i just like it so it's a lifestyle
change
you have to change yeah you have to
change your eating habits and you have
to change your laziness
you have to change your mindset about
starting tomorrow and doing this you
[ __ ] start immediately you gotta just
do it
you gotta get out there and you gotta
force yourself to move
the only way to [ __ ] make yourself
better is to do things you really don't
like to do
and force yourself to do and you're
gonna learn it's gonna become something
that's embedded in you
and that's what i do that like when i go
to the gym i do the [ __ ] that sucks i do
the hardest [ __ ]
i ask for the hardest circuits the
longest the [ __ ]
most strenuous the [ __ ] that makes me
want to [ __ ] barf that i'm
drenched in sweat but when i'm done with
that
and i've achieved there's no highlight
that
you know is it uh what's the one thing
you miss eating the most
since you've started i really just i
crave
pasta and i crave pizza i don't really
like nothing i'm not even like
once you're off the suites for like two
weeks you're done
you get that out of your system i think
a month or whatever whatever it is
you're just done with it you don't need
that [ __ ] no more
i just need [ __ ] pasta in every kind
of way
filled with cheese filled with this one
baked
i feel like but you could have pizza
once in a while without the cheese you
know
even with the cheese i like you know you
gotta have it once in a while
so you can you cut down every day
did you cut dairy out of your diet fully
ninety percent i do
shave some parmigiano-reggiano on things
but it's more of like a
hard aged cheese which really doesn't
count it's like
eating [ __ ] natural yeast
natural yeast i like to [ __ ] think of
it in that way
nutritional yeast